just when i thought i could take it easy
this week and work on some of my regular
scheduled videos
nintendo does it again and hits us with
another bombshell regarding age of
calamity
i'm not gonna do a frame by frame
analysis as it seems kind of moot at
this point you can bet there's going to
be plenty of those in the in coming
hours and days ahead
what i want to do is just give my two
cents in theory about some of the stuff
we saw and especially the ominous figure
at the end
so let's do a quick dive into it one
question that a lot of people probably
have is
is this the same master koga from breath
of the wild i mean their appearance and
body language definitely looks pretty
much identical
but that doesn't necessarily mean this
is the same person by any means
as we all know the yiga are former shika
which means their lifespan should be
about the same
unless koga has always been overweight
and is still as nimble as he's always
been in breath the wild
i find it kinda hard to believe that the
koga from breath the wild is the same
person but now 120 years old
not to mention the trailer seems to hint
that link and co will have an
encounter with koga at some point in the
story but the koga we see in breath of
the wild
doesn't recognize the link from his
appearance the only reason he knows that
link is the one they've been looking for
is because he spots the sheikah slate on
his hip this wouldn't make sense if this
is indeed the same person
unless koga has somehow forgotten which
doesn't really add up
how can you forget your arch-nemesis
there are plenty of people who've
already pointed out that koga isn't
necessarily a name
but rather a title kinda like sensei
from his voice he doesn't exactly sound
like a 20 year old
so i'm predicting that this is not the
same person i mean we don't even know
what the guy looks like underneath his
mask
so even though their general appearance
looks similar we cannot really confirm
anything at this point
we've already seen with impan paya that
descendants apparently can look pretty
much identical besides koga himself we
also see a new yiga member never before
seen in breath of the wild
from the looks of it he is basically a
more badass blade master
most likely a second in command or
general of sorts he's wielding a double
wind cleaver instead of one and the wind
cleavers themselves also slightly differ
from the usual ones
as the ones we see here have four points
on the hilt whereas the original wind
cleavers have three
his mask is also damaged with some sort
of a scar running diagonally across it
indicating that he's probably seen some
action other than that there isn't
really much to say about this new
character other than the fact that
he is clearly boss material but let's
move on to the real eye catcher in this
teaser
this mysterious figure shown at the end
actually this person is already shown
earlier in the teaser right here
and this scene clearly takes place
inside the grand entrance of the yiga
clan hideout
as we can see one of the statues in the
background so whoever this figure is
they are present at the hideout and
conspiring alongside koga and this new
yiga general guy
also the candle in the foreground is
very smartly placed in front of the
backside of this person's robe
fast forward to the end of the teaser
and we can see why the robe has the
grudo symbol on it
i've also seen some people suggest that
he's holding a staff but
i don't know about you guys but it
doesn't really seem like a staff to me
the way this red orb bops up and down
seems more like it's floating in mid-air
we don't really see it attached to a
stick
and we also don't see a stick on the
ground in either of the two shots
anyway we'll go over what the orb could
mean later in the video
the final shot reveals the upper half of
this elusive figure's face
after which we get a fade out similar to
the ones we've seen in previous teasers
as well as the memories from breath of
the wild
now i've already seen so many
suggestions floating around about the
possible identity of this mystery person
twin rova agonim the fortune teller
talked about in breath of the wild's
backstory
a twilight a zonai yeah you get the
point
of course until the game actually comes
out these will just remain speculations
just like with master koga
so i'm just gonna give you my prediction
slash theory about this and we can see
how right
or wrong i was when the game comes out
first off i'm gonna save myself the
headache right now and say
i think this person is a woman the eye
shadow and the face
structure definitely seems to hint in
that direction so i'm just gonna call
this figure she
from now on or else i'm gonna have to
constantly switch up my wording which
ruins the flow of the video
there is another reason why i draw this
conclusion it's not just based on
physical appearance but i will explain
that later
but if it turns out that this person is
something else i apologize in advance
for being wrong
aside from the gerudo symbol on the
cloak we can also see that she wears
jewelry on her forehead which seems to
symbolize ganon's malice eye which is
very interesting in and of itself as
we've never seen this symbol before
whoever this person is she seems to know
about ganon's malice form
even though he hasn't been seen for the
last 10 thousand years
and pretty much nobody else seems to
have remembered his existence
so either she is an extremely old entity
or the knowledge about calamity ganon
has been passed on to her
which ties into the question of what is
she exactly
what kind of people or race does she
belong to well if the grudo symbolism on
her cloak wasn't enough
which could of course just be a tribute
but look at the eye color
they are yellow which rays historically
had yellow eyes
the ancient gerudo from the distant past
including ganondorf himself
besides that we also have the eye shadow
which is also a typical trait of the
gerudo women from that era
so my conclusion is that this person is
probably an ancient gerudo
i don't necessarily think it's twin
rover though it could be but i'm hoping
that nintendo is a bit more creative
than that and this will
be a completely new character we haven't
seen before whatever the case may be
this seems to be a gerudo from the
ancient times unlike the modern day
gerudo which don't have yellow eyes and
have pointy ears from thousands of years
of crossbreeding with hylian men
this one seems to be old school this is
further evident from the fact that
ganondorf's corpse seen in the e3
trailer
still has rounded ears check out mass
nintendo bandit's video about this
if this person indeed turns out to be a
gerudo that solidifies even further that
she has to be female since
well according to the lore of the gerudo
no more than one male exists at the same
time
this could mean that this mystery person
and ganondorf come from the same era
which would be amazing
the next question would be what is her
role in this story
well if you ask me i think she could
very well be the fortune teller who
deceived the royal family into digging
up the divine beasts and the guardians
i've mentioned before in earlier videos
that i believe that the fortune teller
may have been a ganon loyalist
and creating a champion states that this
fortune teller disappeared after the
events of the calamity
and may have gone into hiding tell me
this doesn't fit the profile of this
newly introduced character
a character which we haven't seen before
and doesn't show up in breath of the
wild
next let's focus on the orb and yes i am
still calling it an orb as of right now
i refuse to call something a staff until
i see a stick damn it
anyway from its shape it looks to be an
ancient core
ancient course can be found in breath of
the wild and they are basically what
powers the guardians and other machinery
you often obtain one after defeating a
guardian stalker
however by default these cores have a
blue and orange glow
this one glows a reddish pink color
meaning it's probably an ancient core
corrupted with malice and what happens
when calamity ganon corrupts something
with malice
he's able to perceive the world through
that being or object
each corrupted machine or malice
infested being is basically a piece of
ganon's conscience
and i think this cloaked figure is using
this corrupted core to communicate with
ganondorf himself
since well if it's corrupted a piece of
his conscience is in there in my video
about ganondorf the puppet master
i suggested that ganondorf had to have
someone to serve as his eyes above
ground
well this is probably that person this
also explains why the yiga knew
exactly what to do during the calamity
despite their incompetence
they were led by this mystery figure who
in turn is receiving instructions from
the man himself
my prediction is that this core was
purposely corrupted at some point to
serve as
almost like a crystal ball to talk to
the king of evil again
very reminiscent of the crystal ball
from lord of the rings which is called a
palantir
and also used to communicate with the
main baddie sauron
the last option i want to cover is does
this mean we'll get a glimpse of
ganondorf in age of calamity
and again i'm not talking about calamity
ganon which as we know by now is just a
puppet
i'm talking about the corpse hidden
underground i was already kind of hoping
this game would tie into or at least
hint at what is to come in breath of the
wild too but prior to this teaser i
never really saw a way they could
achieve something like that but this
changes everything and we might actually
get to see cutscenes where we see this
cloaked figure
talking to the actual ganondorf and if
she doesn't die in the age of calamity
we might actually see her return in
breath of the wild too
it would be a perfect transition into
the sequel whatever the case may be
this game together with breath the wild
and its upcoming sequel is shaping up to
be the biggest zelda canon story
we've ever seen in zelda history and
that makes me
very happy as always a big thanks for
watching and i will see you all
in the next video hopefully a proper one
this time
give me a break nintendo